like a drunk neighbor in your front yard
Hillary Clinton wandered on to yet
another TV show to crap on the president
you know I was right in the middle of
our government responding to the
horrible effects of the earthquakes in
Haiti so I knew what we're capable of
doing and you know I waited because I
thought you know they don't need me
saying hey send naval assets get the
hospital ship comfort down there but a
couple of days later nothing was
happening so I tweeted if they are the
highest priority of your government in
responding to such a terrible natural
disaster what are what are you people
spending your time doing Yeah right
golfing tweeting watching cable TV she's
a real piece of work
look I don't blame her she's still angry
still bitter still Hillary apparently
finding her grandchildren boring she
cruises the airwaves slamming the guy
who beat her still as people suffer and
the guy who won consoles them at times
she sounds like she's campaigning but
for what it's like this is high school
and she's vying for most likely to clear
a room with her blood-curdling laughs
there's tragedies going on from Vegas to
Puerto Rico and Hillary sees fit to
remind people what she would have done
if she were in charge she would have
done something but during the election
she did almost nothing but lose
she's like a dumped ex who keeps writing
long letters to the guys parents
reminding them how their son screwed up
oh but I saved the best for last
you're gonna love this check out the
female riders at Jimmy Fallon riding
Hillary thank you notes warning to
viewers have a bucket nearby Thank You
Hillary Clinton for handling this
difficult transition with more grace
than I ever could have imagined that
being said call me day or night and I
will be there with a gallon of ice cream
and two spoons to tell you girl you are
so much better than
Thank You Hillary for always sticking to
the issues even as people criticize you
for superficial things like your hair
your wardrobe and your appearance
you showed girls everywhere that
politics isn't a popularity contest
because if it were you would have won by
about three million votes I was with her
I'm still with her and right now I
literally am with her
[Applause]
[Music]
that is amazing they're treating her
like a lonely friend who lost one of her
six cats no that's not Joan of Arc not
even Joan Crawford it's Hillary Clinton
the reason why we have Donald Trump and
the more that we see ever the more
reassured Americans are that they made
the right choice so Hillary there's the
door
to quote Sam alone of cheers you don't
have to go home but you can't stay here
all right Dana there has to be something
better for her to do but you have to say
you've written several books you've done
book tours have you ever seen anything
like this no even this is the longest
book tour in the world
yes exactly every night and getting all
this attention I don't know
Jesse those letters kind of show you the
mindset of those who work in TV comedy
and entertainment it's kind of cute I
mean it was cute and sad and cute and
sad though I don't even want to say
anything about this I mean I'm gonna get
in trouble if I say what I really that
was humiliating and they should be mad
at Hillary because she blew it Andrew I
don't Trump
first of all Hillary's only crooked
she's a liar she get in place outside
the coast of Puerto Rico they had the
hospital ship comfort off the coast of
Puerto Rico that's not true I also want
to know something has the Clinton
Foundation donated to Harvey to Puerto
Rico I want to see the receipts show me
the receipts has Hillary been to Vegas
does the book tour not go to Vegas so
you could easily be in Vegas comforting
victims no but she's the one tweeting
she's Hawking her book for cash while
Trump's comforting victims and Trump's
bailing out people so I don't want to
hear it anymore she's a punchline hey I
want to ask you Maria because I think
it's kind of her fault
I mean she spun she should've won yeah I
mean she had the opportunities if she
had fought gone to Wisconsin she should
have won so them well they could have
been done different I think first of all
there are legitimate criticisms with
some of the things president Trump has
done and I think the fact that Hillary
is making them should not
meaning the rest of us should not take
them seriously we can't just laugh them
off I understand that was like even I
was uncomfortable with that but one
thing you said in your intro I mean you
said that every time they think Hillary
Clinton American voters are more
confident in their decision I actually
if you look at the president's poll
numbers going up wait a second a
basement I mean there's so far and still
beats her he still beats her today if
you look at the poll numbers you would
not want his poll numbers Hillary
Clinton is not the future of the
Democratic Party many times and and so
while I think yes this interesting that
she was the first female nominee in ten
years I want to read her book I'm ready
to move on anything
you say there are some things she could
have done I think visiting Wisconsin is
like a really big Russians went so the
Russians have better advertising than
the Clinton camp Nebraska did but look
at how tone-deaf is that is this as well
for her to be speaking and criticizing
the president yesterday while he was in
Vegas comforting the victims at our
shooting not to mention the fact that he
was also in Puerto Rico on Tuesday so
instead of uniting in the country at a
time where we really need to be unified
in the wake of something so tragic and
horrible
she's dividing the country we also saw
that from Michelle Obama who recently
made comments criticizing the Republican
Party and saying that basically we're
responsible for all the bad you know bad
night criticized not me saying the
basically the entirety the Republican
Party are all white in men and that's
part of the poisonous part of politics
now let's do this that's what we do we
do what they do it everybody does we
just do it better all right just wait
till 2018 my first ill be around